in Silicon Valley disruptions
everybody's favorite buzzword but some
of history's best inventions actually
come from augmenting what's already
there ziba a design consultancy in
Portland took that spirit to heart and
they wondered what everyday activity
could we reinvent with just a little bit
of technology and what they came up with
was a radical new way to send letters
and packages the Signet is a different
approach to shipping rather than finding
a stamp and looking up somebody's
address you simply take this laser
engraving stamp and push it onto the
parcel or the letter it burns in a
unique identifier it's computer
scannable and you leave it outside
everything else is digital everything
else is modern your phone buzzes and
says your package has been picked up
where would you like it to go and you go
into your contact list and you say I
want it to go to her once the package is
on route you can reroute it you can
speed it up you can split the cost with
whoever is going to receive it that's
how it should be the goal of Signet is
really to take an experience that is
mostly filled with frustration that we
sort of just deal with and turn it into
one that is that is delightful and and
memorable one of things we really wanted
to fix was this idea that I need to have
postage to send something and so that's
why the Signet uses a laser marker it's
a circular mark in the center is your
initials or whatever you want that to be
so that's custom to you and that's your
unique identifier then there's a pattern
of dots that are laid in a circle
pattern around that mark and that is
basically your tracking code and then
there's a dynamic security pattern it's
actually called the Yosh pattern which
is used in currency for security also
and so the idea is that you would mark a
custom gauge pattern on top of all that
to make sure that it couldn't be
counterfeit and it was unique in
one-of-a-kind we actually were able to
take a lot of inspiration from the old
wax seals you would dip it this big
heavy metal object in melted wax and you
would seal your scroll with it and that
would be your mark and so we really took
a lot of cues from that because there's
a real satisfaction between this sort of
you know lift press
very simple very satisfying it's when we
designed the object we're really looking
at one evoking that form so it's got a
base that base is actually where the
charging component is held and you lift
it off and the stamp is on the bottom of
the object so it's very reminiscent of
those old wax seals and then we started
to think about well this is something
that like one of those seals represents
your crest or your family it should
really be something that's made of
natural materials so the process in
which we made it because we wanted to
use real materials we wanted to use wood
so we wanted to use metals we use some
very traditional manufacturing actually
we went and use the lathe we use the CNC
machine and we used different ways to
combine those materials together it
feels weighted it feels substantial it
feels like you mean business with it a
little bit and it feels like a device
that is here to last and not be replaced
the most exciting piece for me actually
is that it frees up the whole front of
the package of the envelope so if I'm
sending a letter to somebody it actually
makes it more human I think because now
I get to write and draw all over the
face of that letter so that when they
get it you know they know immediately
this is from Malcolm and you know it's a
lot more personal so you get it it
allows you to to make shipping and
personal basically it's very rare now
for you to receive something in the mail
that was actually touched by the hands
of somebody that you know and what's
exciting to me about this project is it
does everything possible to encourage
people to start doing that again to make
it as easy as sending a text message and
I find that thrilling something is
ubiquitous ismaïl shows us that we live
with friction in our everyday lives and
just by eliminating a little bit of it
you can actually open up a lot of space
for delight